σε ότι αφοράτα και ο πολιτικά τώρα χειρίζεται σωστάτες όλες καταστάσεις ι επαφές που ε
συνεργασείας συνεγώκάμε άλλες χώρες το ιτονίζουν ότι οι κύπρος δετ θα γίνει ορμητήριον για τν
βαρδισμούς ι ότι δημο για τον συγκεκριμένοι περίσταση για την περιότων ώρα η συγκεκριανη περίσταση
διότι γεννικά πιστεύω ότι κυβέρνηση έχει μια πολύ καλή σοτερικλήσόότερική μπορεί νομίζω ότο έίχαμε πίο
όλοι νιώθω ότι για τη συγκεκριμένη περίσταση υπήρξε να επερβολή της κυβέρνησης η οποία οδήγησε
και σε να να συζήτηση η οποία ναι η δημοσεοποίηση τον συγκεκριμένο στιχείον μπορεί να
ηταλλαθασμένι ήταν λαθασμένι μπορεί να υλαθαμένη τώρα εν βλέπω εμπλοκίνη της ευρώπης ρα διαδή βλέπω
απουσία τις ευρώπες αυτε τη στημή μπορεί να διαψευτώ ότι την υμερα που να υκή
έκπομπινοεί να διαψευτοίδε και θέμα διάψεσης σήμερα νεν υπάρχει βλέπω ότι δεν μπορούμε εμείς πραγματικά
να επηρεάσουμε ότι δήπτε η γίνεται να μη μπορεί να μη μπορεί ευρώπιολόκληρι να επηρεάσει
ότι δήποτε γίνεται στη μέσυν αναδολή καινό πουν μπορούμε και πρέπει να επιγεντρωθεί την αποψη
μου κυβέρνηση νενεί την επίδραση που θα έχει χουν αυτά πάνω μας η απε μπλοκί
ωσο γίνεται χωρίς όμως έχει σημμασία ότι ότι έχουμε και υποχρώσεις εναντί φίλον κρατών στο
βαθμό μου μπορούμε να είμαστ να έχουμε να είμαστε μην πλεγμένε στο όλοζήτημα πρέπει να
το κάμουμε δεν δεν υπάρχει επιωσή να ι είμαστε πλήρως να υπάρχει πλης απεμπλοκι